Welcome.
This is Jocko podcast number two with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Okay,
good evening.
I go,
So people ask me regularly what books I like.
In fact,
Tim Ferris asked me,
which he asks all of his guests,
um,
what books I have given to people,
what books I regularly give to people,
how do I,
what,
what books do I gift?
Which I actually am not a real big gift giver for some reason.
I don't know why,
but uh,
I don't really expect gifts from people and people of the world.
It should not expect gifts from me.
Either lessons,
not gifts.
Yes,
less so.
But there is one book that I,
yeah,
have given to a few people in my life and it is a book that was and still is
very influential on me and especially on my perspective of leadership and really
especially in combat leadership.
And that book is called about face.
Now here it is right here about face.
If you can't,
if you're listening to audio,
it's an 800 over 800 page book.
It's written by a guy named Colonel David Hackworth.
Yeah.
Hackworth was a kind of a soldier's soldier and born in 1930 he joined the
merchant marines towards the end of World War Two at the age of 14 had to lie to
get into the merchant.
Marines got done with that Gig.
He joined the army just after World War Two.
What do you mean?
Sorry?
He had to lie to get into them?
So he was too young.
He was 14 years old.
He lied about his age to get in at 14 to the merchant marines.
When he went a few years later to join the army,
he was still too young and had to lie again to get into the army.
Once he was in the army,
he went over to Europe and he served directly underneath the war hardened
veterans of World War Two and those are the guys that brought him up in the
ranks
and taught him
okay.
About hard training and really that's what they taught him in.
And again,
that's one of those things that I look back on my military career and the
Vietnam veterans that were still in the seal teams when I just got in the seal
teams in 1990 1991,
there were still some,
some veterans around from Vietnam.
And those guys,
when those guys spoke,
you listened because they had some word to put out.
And I absolutely listened to in a lot of those lessons that those guys taught
me,
those with Vietnam veterans taught me.
I carried onto them.
I mean,
I,
I held onto him and took notes and pass them on.
And a lot of those concepts are the basis of,
of what we wrote about in extreme ownership.
So he did that.
He ended up getting,
uh,
Fighting Korea.
So Korea was kind of his,
uh,
where he first saw combat.
He ended up getting a battlefield commission.
And if you don't know what that means,
that means you're,
you're one of the foot soldiers and all of a sudden they go,
look,
you're a good leader.
We're going to put you in charge.
And that's exactly what happened to him.
He was wounded four times before the age of 21.
So the guy was a warrior.
I am going to read his,
uh,
read the book dedication here from the beginning of about face.
It says dedication to Steve Present [inaudible] who is one of the World War II
combat hardened veterans that taught him how to soldier.
So it says to see present [inaudible] who showed us how to soldier,
to Henry Deboer,
who showed us how to die to Glover Johns,
who showed us how to lead and to all the doughboys,
the ground pounders,
the grunts,
the American infantry men,
past,
present,
and especially future to them.
This book is dedicated.
So we wrote this book obviously to pass on the lessons that he learned.
And I got to make a note here and read a little section cause he talks about
Henry Deboer who showed us how to die.
So this took place in the Korean War and I'll go right into it.
They're in a big firefight.
And here's Hackworth.
I saw a soldier prone on the ice.
He'd been there a long time.
I thought he was dead.
But then I saw movement and I rushed out to get him.
My God,
I thought it's to Buer
private.
Henry [inaudible] had been with George companies since early in the war.
He was one of the few survivors from the original third platoon,
basically because in those first hard months of combat,
he had not seen even one good firefight.
He had an uncanny sixth sense.
He could always tell when the platoon was in for a major bloodletting and
invariably he'd find an excuse to be somewhere else.
So here's a guy that Hackworth is saying this guy was avoiding combat,
finding excuses.
Normally that excuse was going on sick call,
which by regulation he was allowed to do and you couldn't stop him even though
you knew the only thing that was wrong with him was a chronic case of cowardice.
So absolutely it's being called a coward.
Deboer himself even admitted he was a coward and we hated him for it.
He was an outcast from the platoon.
We even had a little song about him,
which we'd sing in unison out of the dark jury.
Korean countryside comes the call of the debris or bored,
sick call,
sick call.
He pulled this,
he pulled his stunt only yesterday as we were saddling up for this very
operation,
he'd sensed the bloodletting.
All right,
but he hadn't figured that the foggy overcast covering the battlefield would not
lift and the attack would be postponed.
He'd returned from the dock last night with a clean bill of health.
Most surprised to see us.
The rest of the platoon took great pleasure in the fact that his malingering
little ass would be in the thick of things in the morning.
So he,
there was a big operation planned and he was supposed to go on it.
He snuck out,
went to sick call,
said he's sick.
The them,
the operation got postponed because of weather.
He shows back up and here he is in the scrap praying that he missed.
I didn't miss it.
Now back to the book.
Now Deborah was ashen faced,
hit in the chest or gut,
I don't know.
There was a lot of blood and well into shock.
I knew he wasn't going to make it.
Come onto Buer.
You're going to be fine.
You'll be all right.
I said,
giving him the old pep talk as I grabbed his jacket color and started sliding
across the ice,
but to Booher said,
no,
sarge,
just leave me.
You're going to get hit.
Just leave me sarge.
Then suddenly he groaned.
Sarge,
I shit my pants and that was it.
He was gone.
I left him and ran back to Buer in death became one of the greatest heroes of
our outfit.
It was true.
He'd never been anything in his army life,
but a coward.
But he died,
right?
He died like a man.
He didn't say,
take care of me.
He said,
leave me.
Take care of yourself.
And when I told the other guys the story,
old deboer became a legend in the platoon.
So that's the kind of thing that Hackworth saw as a young leader.
From there.
You know,
he,
when the Korean War ended,
he was again highly decorated.
Korean War ended,
did time in a bunch of different units in between the Korean War and the Vietnam
War.
When the Vietnam War kicked off,
he went right into the thick of it again,
ended up as a battalion commander in Vietnam.
And here's his,
here's his list of awards to Distinguished Service Crosses,
10 silver stars,
four legions of Merit,
distinguished flying cross eight bronze stars,
eight Purple Hearts.
So you have a guy here that is a
obviously a highly dedicated soldier,
a guy that would do anything for the army and for America.
But,
and this is a big,
but
this guy was a rebel.
He was a true rebel and he went out and went against his officers.
He went against what the way the army was running the war in Vietnam.
And eventually he went out in public on national television and spoke out
against the Vietnam War and said that we should not fight there anymore.
So he went on this TV program is called issues and answers.
It was a big show in the,
uh,
in the 70s.
And he did this interview.
And again,
you've got to remember this guy has an active duty,
an active duty,
highly decorated senior officer in the army.
I mean,
this guy is all by all accounts should be the most dedicated
and here he is and this is what he says.
You know,
this is one of the quotes from this interview.
I think that the top managers of the army,
and there's a big difference between a leader,
a combat leader and a manager.
The top managers were so involved in systems analysis in the normal bureaucracy
of it all.
They were that they were fighting from day to day just to move paper that
crossed their desk and they couldn't see the forest for the trees.
In February when we went into Laos,
we went into Laos conventionally,
the idea was to block the enemy's supply routes.
So we dropped in there,
we paid a horrible,
the Vietnamese paid a horrible price.
Tremendous mistakes were made.
Again,
conventional thinking.
He,
he's gonna he hounds on this a lot.
This idea of conventional thinking.
And again,
you got a guy that's institutionalize me.
The guy's been in military service and he was 14 years old.
You'd think that they would have him mentally sedated to a point where he would
just think what they tell him to thin,
but he does not.
That's the dichotomy of this guy.
Again,
conventional thinking,
conventional thinking put us in that operation rather than have a light mobile
guerrilla force,
but a guerrilla force that belonged to the government of Vietnam or an American
army operating in their light gorilla.
So he was saying the Vietnamese should be doing this.
The the South Vietnamese army should be doing this or if we're going to do it,
we need to operate like gorillas.
It takes a thief to catch a thief.
What we need is a thief.
We don't need a conventionally trained FBI agent dashing through the woods with
a large force behind him.
We need small people,
well trained,
highly motivated.
And this is what we have not had because what we have now,
and this is where you say to yourself,
wow that because what we have now among the army is a bunch of shallow
dilettantes who run from pillar to post trying to punch their card,
serving minimum time at company level.
Because the exposure,
you are very close to the heat of the furnace there meaning you can get in
trouble easily.
So he is on national television,
a colonel in the army,
one of the most highly decorated individuals at the time and he calls,
he says the army is filled with a bunch of shallow dilettantes who run from
pillar to pillar to post trying to punch their card and purposely avoiding
combat is what that second piece mates.
You don't see this kind of behavior from army officers very often.
I will tell you that.
Um,
and here's Kinda how he closed it out.
She says,
uh,
hit the interviewer.
They are sorry.
He says,
the interviewer says,
colonel,
do you think,
do you feel it's possible you have become too emotionally involved in Vietnam?
And he says,
I have become emotionally involved in Vietnam.
One couldn't have spent a number of years I spent in Vietnam without becoming
emotionally involved.
One couldn't see the number of young studs die or be terribly wounded without
becoming emotionally involved.
I just have seen the American nation spent so much of it's wonderful,
great young men in this country.
I've seen our national wealth being drained away.
I see the nation being split apart and almost being split asunder because of
this war.
And I am wondering to what end it is all going to lead to.
So
that is a devastating statement.
And when it came out,
they immediately,
he put in his resignation papers immediately and the army started to investigate
them immediately.
And they tried to,
they tried to get him in trouble for every little minor infraction that had
happened underneath his command at any time,
in any situation.
They really tried to come after him and he ended up retiring.
And
you know,
I think one of the things that he expressed there is a dichotomy that any buddy
in a combat leadership position will feel.
And that is,
and I don't,
I in fact,
this might be the largest dichotomy of all.
And that's a big statement.
And that is as a combat leader,
you are
told and beyond being told you aren't ingrained and beyond being ingrained,
you are inherently inherently caring of your guys.
There is no one more important than your guys.
And the dichotomy is as much as you care about these guys and you love these
guys and you do anything for them.
But that being said,
it is your job to send these guys on operations that can kill them.
And
so that is
a huge dichotomy.
And I think that's one of the things that Hackworth,
when he saw it on a grand scale,
because he could deal with it in his own groups,
but when he saw it on a grand scale,
you know,
we young men being
sent to their death,
it's,
it,
I think what,
what turned him.
Um,
so
he ended up after this,
you know,
he kind of continued down that path and he moved out of America.
He moved to Australia and he
ended up
kind of playing a big role in the anti nuclear weapons movement.
And I mean that's kind of where he went.
So I,
you know,
hack was a complex person,
Hackworth,
that's kind of his nickname.
Everyone calls him hack hack was a complex person.
And I don't agree with everything that he says.
I don't agree with everything that he does and everything that he did.
I don't worship a guy.
Uh,
and you know,
What's interesting about me questioning what his decisions and questioning his
leadership.
It's like,
that's something I learned from him.
Like,
don't even,
don't listen to anybody 100%.
Don't put,
you know,
you should always be questioning what people are saying and,
and making sure and confirming it through other sources and other experiences
that it's the right thing to do.
And that's something that I always try to do with everything is,
is used that attitude.
And
so I,
I,
I don't,
I don't recall,
and I was actually trying to come in here tonight.
I was trying to figure out when I got this book,
and I actually have no idea.
I don't remember it.
It like appeared in my life at some point and I don't know how,
I don't want,
never made the recommendation to me.
I just somehow ended up with it and,
but I got it.
I got it before.
One thing I do know is I got it before September 11th,
2001 when that happened,
I had already read it.
I'd had it in my brain.
But when I was in Ramadi in 2006 this,
I read this book every night that I was not out in the field.
I read this book every night and you know,
I just open it up.
You could open up anywhere in that,
in this book and you could find something,
some,
some piece of information,
some similar situation,
some lesson learned that you could take from it and it could guide you and,
and you're one of the like,
like for instance,
and it all applied to what I was doing.
The situation I always in.
So,
for instance,
we were in Iraq and we were supposed to be working with Iraqi soldiers who are
unmotivated,
poorly equipped,
poorly trained on educated,
bad morale and that's and corrupt.
So there the money's all disappearing.
It's,
it's a horrible situation.
And what was Hackworth doing in Vietnam where they were working with the South
Vietnamese army who was corrupt and unmotivated and poorly trained and all those
same things that they were dealing with,
the same things we were dealing with.
And that's one example of many.
Uh,
I took a little break
about three months into deployment.
I took a little break in and I'm not 100% sure why,
but I found another book,
somebody had left a book in our building and the book was speaking of Dichotomy.
The book was the electric koolaid acid test by Tom Wolfe.
And I think at this point,
I,
you know,
three months into deployment,
I think I needed some kind of mental escape,
you know,
at least,
I was close.
I was like dealing with combat all day.
And then I'd go in my room and Redo about combat at night.
And I kind of was like,
okay,
you need to think about something else for 20 minutes or 10 minutes and just get
out of get get it out of your head.
And I randomly found this book,
so I said,
oh,
and I had read the right stuff by Tom Wolf,
which was a fantastic book.
And so I said all this,
I'm sure this will be interesting as well.
So as I read this book,
the electric Koolaid acid test,
which is about hippies and drugs and the 60s and that's what it's about,
Haight Ashbury,
the whole nine yards.
And there's a quote in the middle of that I actually pulled out because I will
never forget this quote and how this quote was so starkly contrasting with about
face and,
and I'm going to read this quote and these and I kind of forget the whole setup
to it,
but they're at some kind of a concert and there's all this screaming and
craziness going on at some rock and roll concert.
And you know,
he says,
I couldn't hear what they were screaming either,
but you don't have to.
They're screaming,
me,
I'm me.
That's the cry of the ego.
And that's the cry of this rally,
this concert,
Mi,
Mi.
And that's why wars get fought.
Ego because enough people want to scream,
pay attention to me.
And it was one of those things that I read night and it was so stark.
We different from the situation that I was in where I was with these guys in my
own task into the seals and my task unit,
the Marines that were there on the ground with us,
the army soldiers that were down on the ground hold us.
And these guys were all so selfless.
The last thing they cared in the world about was me,
me,
me.
And I got done with that book and I went right back to about face because I,
I related to it,
I understood and I said to myself,
this is true,
this is selfless.
This is where I'm at right now.
Yeah.
So I went back into about face and I continued and eventually this book is the
one book that I've given to a few of the guys that worked closely for me,
uh,
including included Leif,
Leif Babin who,
you know,
one of my brothers who wrote extreme ownership with me and he's one of the guys
that,
you know,
he's got,
he's got his copy and it's all dog eared and marked up because it's a great
book.
Yeah.
So obviously when we like on Twitter and Facebook and we asked for people to
give us questions,
a lot of the questions are,
a bunch of questions are about
leadership.
And so I kind of,
as I thought about diving in a little bit,
two,
this book and,
and,
and talk about it a little bit.
And of course you could spend,
you know,
we could do 50 episodes,
10 hours each on this book.
There's so it's so dense and filled with information.
Not to mention it's 800 pages long.
There's,
um,
but I wanted to,
I wanted to go a little bit deep on this one situation where David Hackworth,
Colonel Hackworth had now gone into Vietnam and there was a,
a battalion of soldiers and they were kind of a disaster.
They were kind of the standard of like what,
what had happened with some of the,
the poor leadership in Vietnam.
And he took over and again,
just to kind of,
to kind of lay out what Hackworth was like,
here's a quote that kind of starts off the chapter.
Hackworth was essentially a legend just before he arrived.
I recall going to the g one and asking who the new battalion commander was going
to be.
The deputy g g one said,
can't tell you,
you know how personnel people are,
they like to hit pocket everything,
but he's Mr Infantry.
I thought,
who the hell is mentioned?
Mr Infantry.
Of course I'd read about David h Akward.
So his kind of nickname was Mr infantry.
That was his reputation.
What does hip pocket mean?
Meaning,
if the people that are in charge of,
uh,
personnel and moving people around inside the military,
they know,
they know little bits of information and instead of giving it to you,
they keep it,
they keep it close to keep it in their hip pocket.
That's all it means.
And then,
uh,
to,
to kind of explain though that,
you know,
there's some people that go,
yeah,
this guy's a,
this guy's a great leader.
He's coming in,
but to kind of show you what the attitude of the troops is,
you got to remember this is Vietnam.
We got draftees,
we got hippies,
we got all kinds of anti American.
I mean,
it's crazy times.
Uh,
doc Holly,
there's another quote for who's it from a medic.
Charles Winsor,
doc Holly and I were sitting in the aid station drinking beer and saying,
God,
this is going to be hell.
We've got some GI Joe Life route here is going to just ruin us.
That was probably the lowest point of morale.
And the battalion,
not only had we been taking a lot of casualties,
but now it looked as if someone was going to come in and kick ass and make a
manmade career soldiers out of us.
And it goes on to go through more quotes where they actually talk about a price
on his head.
The,
the soldiers talked about,
hey,
we,
we need to kill this guy before he gets us killed,
which is just kind of crazy.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
You know,
you hear about that,
you hear about that Vietnam,
this idea of,
it's called fragging.
There's a name for it.
They were going to frag our officer meetings.
We're going to kill our own officer.
And it's something that definitely happened and,
and it's,
uh,
okay.
Yeah.
This is a perfect case of where people talked about it possibly happening.
So
to get into this chapter a little bit,
hmm,
here's Hackworth,
talking about when he took over,
there was no sense in showing this sorry outfit.
I was in a state of shock.
It wasn't just the command post group that it wasn't just that the command post
group slept on cots inside tents that they had folding chairs and state side
footlockers portable radios and plastic coolers filled with beer and coke at
their fire base out in the field.
More than that it was that they had portable toilets to,
so here he is,
these guys are supposed to be out in the field and they have all this luxury and
that's something that we saw in Iraq where there was certain bases where they
had a Starbucks and subway sandwiches and Mcdonald's literally had those things
and you the further you go out into the fray you get guys,
I've in revisiting some of my first deployment to Iraq,
we'd go out to some,
there'd be guys you know completely in the bush living like gs,
barely scraping by on one MRE a day.
So
now he's talking about the command post and he says that the command post
apparently were blissfully unaware that just nearby their troops were crapping
on the ground and not even covering it up.
So you have complete just disaster situation going on here.
And then the,
the general that's in charge of all these battalions as he's about to put
Hackworth in charge.
Guy Named General Ewell says it's a pussy battalion and I want tigers,
not pussies,
but he'd gotten it wrong with the fourth battalion,
39 and 39th infantry.
That's where he's taken over.
It was not a question of feline degree as far as I could see.
This unit was not even a military organization,
so that's,
that's what this guy walked into,
Como Hackworth.
It was total.
He goes on to say it was total disintegration throughout the Firebase Ma amid
the shit and toilet paper and the machine gun ammo laying in the mud where
troops were wore love beads and peace symbols and look more like something out
of Haight Ashbury than soldiers in the U s army.
All we're low on spirit and a few were high openly on marijuana.
There was minimum security,
few men carried are cared for their weapons.
Most had let them go read with rust as they strolled around without them,
grenades weren't taped and when a unit moved out,
most of the gunners wore their ammo.
Pancho villa style,
the ideal way to guarantee a weapon jam sometime down the track when dirty
dented cartridges were inserted into their sixties so what we have here is a
total lack of discipline.
And another thing that this reminded me of was I was always trying to,
when I was in the seal teams also trying to pull as much information about war
as I could.
And one of the recent wars in recent times was when the Russians went into
Chechnya the first time and they,
they had a really hard time and I read the after actions reports from the
Russian officers that had taken troops there and one of the ones that I
remembered,
I've looked forward to try and find it again.
I don't know if it's clean,
I don't know.
I don't know where it went but I,
I haven't been able to find it.
But the guy basically says it all started when the guys stopped shaving and when
they stopped shaving then they,
then the next thing you knew they weren't cleaning their guns.
Then the next thing you knew they weren't
staying aware while they were on watch.
And then the next thing you know,
they were getting overrun and killed.
So those little things,
those little things that you do right all the time are important.
And that's the same thing with you.
And with me and with our lives,
it's those little things,
those little disciplines,
those little daily disciplines.
We'll cycle like you waking up at four 30 in the morning,
like me,
wait,
like as a ritual,
you know,
that's one of them at,
I try and do something physically active every day.
That's another thing.
When you lose that discipline,
what goes next?
The next thing on the lidding really.
And then the end of the next thing,
you know,
you're sleeping in until nine,
you're not getting your work done and things are going horribly backwards.
But it's those little disciplines.
Yeah.
And,
and whenever I feel myself start to slip,
I always think of this.
I always think of the fact that there's these little disciplines that means so
much and they build on each other.
It's interesting is that I didn't,
I didn't really look at it that way ever.
And that makes complete sense where,
yeah,
you let the little things slide and slowly by slowly those things that you let
slide start getting bigger and bigger.
I always thought of it where I remember hearing somebody say,
if you can't make your bed right,
right.
Then how do you expect to run a company?
I think it was how do you expect to be the boss of a company?
And I remember thinking,
well,
unless your company is a bed making company that has nothing to do with it.
And this is also a little bit counter to something I've heard recently.
And when they talk about have you heard of this decision fatigue?
Have you heard that?
Not Static.
So it's basically this theory where every decision you make take some sort of
toll on you mentally.
Yes.
And so you should,
you should not fatigue your,
your decisions.
You should only should save your decisions for important things.
So for instance,
is that Kinda like if you're with a group of people and once one guy says,
hey,
where do you guys want to eat?
And everyone says,
oh,
I don't care.
Where do you want to?
It's different.
It's the same thing.
Maybe in a way lower level,
but,
but the level of this is when I heard about this decision fatigue,
the level that I heard this on was a
like
you every day you don't,
you shouldn't think about what you're going to wear that day.
You should have your clothes ready because if you wake up,
you have to think,
oh,
do I wear the blue shirt or the white shirt and,
and it becomes decision and then you decide,
or what am I going to have for breakfast?
I have this,
we have that.
And each one of these decisions chip away now.
Now that's fine.
I don't really,
I don't know if I believe that 100% but one thing I do think is the opposite is
I think that the smaller disciplines
instill and create stronger disciplines.
So the waking up early,
the making of the bed,
the the checking off your list,
that all those little things that you do,
I think increased discipline.
I know what you went.
When I fall off the discipline wagon for whatever reason,
it's like a,
it's like a train wreck,
you know,
I'm like,
oh my God,
what just happened?
I'm all of a sudden my room is a mess in my,
it just goes down hill in three days and two days and I go,
oh my,
get back in the game.
So and then as soon as I get back in the game and I implement those smaller
disciplines,
boom,
we're back in the game and the and the bigger disciplines fall into place.
So
continue now
there was a general
that had
swung through Vietnam,
General James Wool.
No.
And
he observed,
and this is going to the book General James We'll know,
observed and wrote to the chief to chief of staff Westmoreland.
We all knew that is less than a month before.
So before this,
he had showed up before Hackworth had showed up.
This Guy General James wore wool.
No had observed and wrote to chief of staff Westmoreland less than a month
before,
during his whirlwind,
nine day trip to the war zone.
We'll know.
Told the chief that the most you that the almost universal opinion among those
he'd spoken with was that the young officers and enlisted men being sent to
Vietnam were indeed properly trained,
prepared for combat both by training and mental conditioning.
So this guy wrote this flowery report after he goes,
goes to Vietnam for nine days and you can imagine somebody like Hackworth that
spent five years in Vietnam,
somebody shows up,
spends nine days there.
He's looking at this guy like he's knee idiot.
Yeah.
And this is a,
a classic
mmm.
Statement about leadership.
He said,
this is Hackworth going directly to the book again,
what a mistake it was to listen to the generals of corporate HQ who were briefed
only in zero defect terms and so far from the cutting edge expected nothing
less.
It was among the biggest mistakes of the war.
The politicians only listened to these generals and these generals to
themselves.
That's,
that's crazy.
And this is again,
when I was talking about questioning earlier and I like I questioned Hackworth
and I question everybody and everything.
I'm constantly asking those questions because you don't know.
You don't know if you're just listening to the generals that are only listening
to themselves.
Back to the book.
Few people ask the frontline soldiers,
the only ones who really knew.
So
you got to talk to your frontline troops.
Yeah.
That's just a mandatory piece of leadership.
Uh,
I liked it.
I had a great word on this.
It's called incestual knowledge,
right?
When the,
when this little group just talks among themselves and they believe everything
that they hear and they,
and they agree with everything they hear.
And you know where we see this,
we see this and we saw it with mixed martial arts because you saw guys that got
so into their own little thing with no outside influence that when they all
believed their own crap.
Yeah.
And digits.
It can be to fully,
it can be that way and you've got to have an open mind with everything,
you know.
Um,
and definitely Jujitsu is one of the things you got to have an open mind with
him,
see what other people are doing and how are they doing it.
And that's,
that's the miracle these days is you can be seeing getting all this influence
from the Internet.
It was all these different people out there and showing how they're doing it.
And it's,
it's a whole new world.
But you got to have an open mind.
If you haven't,
no,
don't have an open mind.
And all you do is incestuously converse with other people that believe the same
thing as you.
You're wrong.
Um,
and this is crazy.
This is,
this is again,
this is what we'll know,
says what is left.
And he's talking about the,
this Vietnam,
what is left appears to be a mopping up operation.
I do not believe that in the current situation,
the enemy has the capability to more than harass us.
I did not find a division commander who disagreed with this conclusion with
respect to his own tactical area of operations.
This is 1968 and this general is coming back saying,
hey,
the enemy can't do anything but harass us.
Eh,
and that's this.
This guy was the ranking guy going back and reporting to Westmoreland and in
charge of the whole army.
Crazy crazy that this could be taking place.
As we go a little bit deeper into this.
They had a board that explained it was like a scoreboard for how many VC,
Vietcong,
how many of them had been killed or wounded and how many Americans have been
killed or wood.
And when he took over,
when,
when Hackworth took over,
the enemy had zero Kia.
So there've been zero enemy killed,
zero enemy wounded and zero enemy captured.
Meanwhile,
the Americans had had 24 killed and 485 wounded.
So did you hear what I just said?
I did.
So the enemy had zero killed,
zero wounded,
zero captured,
and yet we had lost 24 Americans killed and 485 wounded.
This goes back to what I was talking about where I would see these similarities
in Iraq to Vietnam because these wounded came from rockets,
mortars,
booby traps,
friendly fire
rockets,
mortars,
booby traps in front of fires.
I think 70% of the casualties in Iraq were from Ids,
which an IED is an improvised explosive device.
That's a booby trap.
You know,
the other big percentage was from getting mortared.
where you're sitting inside your Firebase and all of a sudden bombs start
raining down from the sky.
And it's weird to like,
this is something that we talk about often.
It's something that that Hackworth talked about as well,
is if you've ever heard someone say in Vietnam,
we won every major battle,
but we just lost the word.
Have you ever heard that he was a,
it's a,
it's a statement that peep some people make.
And as I started to analyze that,
because when I was younger,
I was like,
yeah,
that's right,
because we're the best military in the world.
We would never lose to these guys were awesome and we are awesome and we are the
best military in the world.
But if I have a platoon of 40 guys in the army and we lose a guy to a booby trap
and we lose a guy to a mortar,
and we,
and we never confront the enemy,
who's going to win the war?
It's not us.
Right?
So that was a very,
uh,
very disturbing.
And we did see some of this,
we did see some of this in Iraq where things would get sugarcoated.
Mm.
And that's one thing.
I'd go back to the book and I'd say,
why are they sugarcoating this?
What's going on?
Somebody needs to speak the truth.
You know,
we need to tell them what's really going on here.
Hey,
I raised my hand and say,
no boss.
It's not like that.
We need this.
We need,
we're,
this is where we're going to lose.
This is what's going wrong.
And Luckily we had some very strong,
you know,
melt military leaders that did that.
You know,
uh,
Petraeus for sure,
who kind of implemented the surge.
We had a McMaster who I talk about a lot,
HR McMaster up in,
uh,
up in northern Iraq.
And you know,
the guy that I worked directly for,
Colonel Sean McFarlin,
who is now a general,
uh,
those guys were guys that spoke the truth.
And I would hear,
I heard Mcfarland do that.
I would hear that guy say,
no,
actually we can't do that.
No,
that's actually the wrong idea.
we actually need to engage with these tribal leaders even though they were
criminals six months ago.
No,
this is what we need to do.
So I got to see some of that leadership step up,
which was,
which was awesome.
Uh,
okay.
He goes on to talk about how
I got to read this.
So he goes to this,
what's called a change of command,
which is when,
you know I'm in charge,
but I'm going to give you the battalion.
So the following day I took over the battalion from Lieutenant Colonel Franklin,
a heart,
you know,
parade field,
change of command in the middle of the Mekong Delta.
What kind of war have I gotten myself into?
I wondered,
a perfectly starched general,
you was there having flown in for the occasion in his polished choppers.
There were,
there were other brass too,
and photographers the American flag,
but the Italian colors,
which were ceremoniously passed onto me and all of this before the scroungy is
most spiritless assembly of soldiers I'd ever seen.
Incredibly.
None of the are colonels seem to notice the slack condition of my new charges or
their positions.
Lieutenant Colonel Frank Cart would still receive a legion of Merit for his job
well done with the battalion.
So picture that in your mind you're taking over this battalion.
These guys are just complete disaster.
The general show up in their polished helicopters wearing starched uniforms and
they don't even,
they just ignore,
it's like they're like got blinders on.
They're just ignoring the fact that these guys are just a total disaster.
Crazy thoughts,
crazy thoughts.
So,
um,
then we get into the point,
okay,
where in this is where,
when we,
when we get these questions on Twitter about leadership,
and this is sort of what drew me back to thinking about talking about this book
was because as we get these questions,
you end up with a,
with a just really great examples and,
and a lot of questions that we get our,
um,
you know,
what do you do with people that are unmotivated?
What do you do when you know,
and,
and everyone has that question of what do you do when people aren't motivated?
And I,
I'll tell you,
can you imagine if there's anyone less motivated then a,
you know,
a construct,
a draftee from Vietnam,
from the Vietnam War.
It's,
it's,
it's kind of crazy.
Sorry,
go ahead.
Yeah,
no problem.
Uh,
one of the things that hacks is his little,
could I have guessed that whipping it into shape,
meaning the battalion would require every little bit bit of knowledge I'd gained
in,
in the interim.
So his whole career,
he realized this whole careers and you have to take every trick that he'd
learned to get these guys into shape.
Now what's interesting about this is he says,
whipping these guys into shape,
and this is something I've had,
I've had executives when I get out,
get on with the CEO and he'll say,
I need you to come in here and a whip my guys into shape.
And it's always,
it's one of those quotes that I,
I have to push back on because they think I'm to come in there like a drill
instructor and bark orders and people are going to obey it.
It just doesn't work that way.
Yeah.
And you know you,
you have to do,
you have to do more than that.
So when one of the initial things that he did
was institute discipline.
Yeah.
And as you know,
discipline is one of my favorite words.
Going back to the book here,
from the outset I realized that to make this unit and effective military force,
I'd have to implement about a thousand.
So I'd figured we'd start with five a day.
Little things,
basic things like where your steel pot helmet and clean and carry your rifle at
all times and ammunition will not be worn.
Poncho via style.
My first order was that calm darkness.
The fire support base perimeter would pull back 300 meters.
The troops instantly began to grumble at this but at the next order.
But it was the next order that really began the muteness feeling within my hard
luck outfit.
Anything you can't carry 24 hours a day is gone on the next shopper.
So here are these guys that were living in tents that had toilets out there,
radios and all this stuff.
And he said,
anything you can't carry with you,
he's going is out of here.
That's hardcore discipline
and
okay,
they piled it all up in the middle of the,
uh,
the middle of the base and had a big helicopter come in and take it out.
Now one thing you said is here is he says,
I wasn't there to have them like me.
And this is one of those dichotomies where,
and I'm sure everybody at one point or another who has worked for someone that
is very abrasive and thinks they can just throw words around and,
and,
and no one likes working for that guy.
It's,
it's awful.
Yeah.
And so there is a fine line between,
listen,
I'm not here to make friends and Oh,
I'm just going to be totally abrasive and treat everyone like crap because
you're not going to get people to follow you with that attitude.
So he obviously was very good at walking that fine line between pushing hard
enough where he's like,
Hey,
I'm not here to make friends.
But at the same time,
not pushing them so hard that he's getting shot or there there's a complete
mutiny against him.
Yeah.
You'd think that someone who,
who
in my experience,
when people say that I'm not here to make friends,
you know,
I'm here to whatever,
it's usually kind of like an excuse because they pissed somebody off.
Yeah.
So I think that to really use that in a,
in a,
in an accurate way or in a,
in a conducive way,
I'm not here to make friends is if you can show them results and at the same
time not necessarily,
you know,
be the nicest of guys,
then I think that's when you start to walk that fine line.
So,
so it's beautiful that you said that.
So this,
this goes right into the fact that,
uh,
a short time later,
so after they pulled back this perimeter,
so every night instead of staying where they were just all relaxed,
they packed up,
they pulled back,
they dug in.
Our short time later we were hit with a barrage of rocket and recoilless rifle
fire.
But most of it fell on the old positions.
When I got on the horn and called for artillery,
I was surprised.
I was very nervous.
Command is not like hopping back onto a bicycle.
And after two and a half years away from it,
I was rusty and actually scared I'd screw up.
But then I heard a guy later do,
I bet be identified as Lieutenant Larry Taller,
who worked in the s three section running behind me to his defensive position.
And here's the quote from this guy,
he's a mean son of a bitch,
but he knows what he's doing.
So that's exactly what you just said and that's exactly what effect it had.
Um,
now moving through this,
the men,
and now he's talking about this unit,
the four,
three,
nine,
the men of the four,
three,
nine,
had no unit identity and no pride in themselves.
So for all those people that are out there that have sent me Twitter question
saying,
hey,
how do I deal with people that are motivated?
How do I,
how do I change?
There's another one.
How does culture change?
Uh,
he's going to go into that as a first step toward rectifying this.
I decided to call my hard luck battalion,
the hardcore and the troops raw condos.
So he's renaming them [inaudible],
he's renaming,
renaming the battalion.
And I actually did this very thing when I was a task unit commander when I took
over a task unit.
So task units in a seal team,
they have a,
a phonetic letter for their name.
So there's out task unit,
Alpha Task Unit,
Bravo Task Unit Charlie.
And then you've got the platoons underneath them.
So what I did with ours is basically as soon as I took it over,
I said,
hey,
we were tasking you to Bravo B.
And I said,
guys,
we're not tasking your Bravo,
we're tasking at bruiser.
And that was one of those things where even though at first people were kind of,
you know what,
what's this all about?
But then,
but then after a little while they're like,
oh no,
no,
cause you're an a task unit.
I'm in task unit bruiser right.
And it,
and it really does have a,
a legit effect.
It's like a little psychological sense of pride.
Like we're this unique kind of almost elite group just in that small little
psychological way.
Yeah.
I think branding,
a lot of that has a lot to do with branding.
Where where um,
you get like a company for example,
um,
you do just little things different and include everyone,
whether it be the name,
whether it be little.
I mean sometimes they do it with them.
It's like team building exercises for sure.
Which I've seen a lot of ones that,
that,
that don't really,
they're not very effective.
But there's certain things that if,
if those activities can kind of invoke a sense of pride and you guys are doing
it together,
that's when that's when that can work.
And the name thing,
it's crazy how that's such a big thing when you're a little bit then when you
have a cool name where like it's almost like a gang mentality.
It is
literally says here they had no unit identity.
So guess what?
He's going to pick that identity,
calm the hardcore,
calm the condo.
He's going to give them that identity and give them something to latch onto and
he goes further.
So he talks about how in the past,
when he was in a,
with another unit,
he,
they had this greeting between officers and enlisted guys and the officer would
say airborne and the enlisted guy would say all the way.
So the airborne all the way.
And so now these guys are in Vietnam and it's a little bit different.
It's a little bit harder.
So now,
and this going back to the book,
when a soldier saluted an officer,
he said hardcore Macondo sir.
And when the officer responded,
it was with a heartfelt no fucking slack.
And I mean it,
it doesn't get any better than that.
And as a matter of fact,
when this is one of the most fired up things,
uh,
when I,
when I retired from the seal teams,
the guys that ran the land warfare training,
so like the most miserable hard training out in the Imperial Valley of
California where it's 120 degrees and you're humping through the desert and it's
just completely hardcore.
And we would,
I mean,
the training was miserable and tough and realistic and bad ass.
And when I left those guys from the Land Warfare Group,
uh,
gave me a shotgun and on the shotgun was engraved,
no fucking slack.
So the,
so you picture these guys walking around,
it's like you just said,
you're talking about unit identity and they give him this name,
but now they're walking on into,
every time they see each other,
they're saying,
hardcore Rick Condo,
no fucking slack.
And I don't care.
That's a mantra,
you know?
And that becomes a mantra that becomes what you say.
And that doesn't take much for what you say to start to become what you believe.
And so I love that.
I love,
and when we work with companies we,
you know,
depending on how long we're working with them for,
we'll sit down and can,
we'll have him come up with a mission statement.
Yeah.
And then we'll come up with some kind of a mantra and I'll tell him this story
about no fucking slack and you know,
like what is gonna make you?
What is going to make you think that way?
Because that's what I used to say,
Atlanta warfare.
You know,
when I was running land warfare training,
you know,
hey,
should we give these guys a little extra time?
Should we give him that?
Should we move the target a little bit closer to the insert point?
Are these,
can we make this a little bit easier for him?
And I'd say no fucking slack.
And the reason was I wanted these guys to be ready.
I wanted every one of those seals that was going to Iraq and Afghanistan to be
ready for anything.
If you ready.
I wanted the training to be harder than real combat.
That was the goal.
And then these,
these little mantras and all these things that kind of gives everyone a sense of
pride in going through that hard training.
Oh,
for sure.
To ultimately result in being ready for them to take pride and enjoyment in that
hard training because of these little tiny things that makes it just that much
more effective.
You know,
the whole,
the whole situation.
It's completely true.
Um,
there's another piece here.
Simultaneous had going back to the,
simultaneously I started establishing standard operating procedures that would
not only keep the troops alive,
but also give them for the first time the feeling they were in charge of the
situation,
not at mercy of the VC or insidious booby traps.
So think about that.
You know,
this,
this idea that you're on the defense all the time and you're constantly like
waiting to get blown up or waiting to get mortared,
awaiting to get a take,
a sniper round.
That's a horrible,
horrible feeling.
Being on the receiving end of that stuff is horrible because you don't have
control over it.
So then they started slowly putting things together too
to go on the offensive sop.
Standard operating procedures included such things as every officer having to
read Mao's little red book.
So this was kind of the communist way and he wanted all the officers to know and
understand that because how can you beat an enemy if you don't know what they're
thinking.
That was another just classic move and you got to think like the enemy.
I've got a couple more things to pull out here.
People talking about.
Um,
you know,
Karen for your guys.
And here's another good,
you know I,
this is going back to the book.
I wasn't going to lose any legs for a couple VC.
I was into fighting hard but not at the expense of bleeding troops.
The fact that I had that,
I walked with the platoons,
put me in the good graces and a lot of men,
but my stock eat rose even faster when they got word.
When word got around that I wasn't a butcher.
So,
even though he was hardcore and he was saying no fucking slack,
what do you,
what he talks about earlier in that paragraph is if he found one of the young
officers was doing something that was careless,
that could put guys at risk of running into booby traps or add that would,
that didn't have a good return,
he'd fire that guy.
He would literally just fire the guy and the,
and so the guys realized,
okay,
this guy is hardcore,
but guess what?
He cares about us and that,
that,
that is huge.
And,
and another piece,
and this is kinda going back to what we just said,
all the four,
three,
nine really needed head need had really needed,
was a good kick in the ass,
which included creating or bringing in leaders who cared for their men and
giving the men some sense of real purpose.
Wow.
You know,
and what we call that in real life,
and I talk about it in the book,
it's the why.
Why are we here?
And you'd be surprised.
It happens with companies,
it happens with families,
it happens in the military.
It happens with teams.
They don't understand why they're doing what they're doing.
They're just doing it as a task,
as a robot.
And you can't treat people like robot.
People have to have some kind of longterm goal.
They have to have an understanding of why they're doing what they're doing.
So that's,
that's like 99% of my answers when somebody says,
Hey,
I've got this problem with these people don't want to follow this rule.
They don't want to do this safety,
uh,
task or safety procedure,
the,
you know,
I can't get my guys to do the safety procedure.
And I'm like,
well,
do they understand why they're doing it?
Well,
what do you mean?
Do they understand why they are doing it?
They understand why they are supposed to clip in at the top of a tower that
they're climbing.
Do they understand why?
Do they understand the implications if they fall?
They understand the implications,
not just to them but to their family.
Are they thinking about the implications to their job or they think about the
implications to the company.
And then on other people's jobs,
you put all those why,
here's why your clip it into that tower.
Because if you fall,
you can't pay your mortgage,
your kids,
he'll can't eat.
Then on top of that,
we have to shut down the tower for week.
We're going to lose money,
we're going to lose jobs.
And when you think about why,
then all of a sudden the guy goes,
okay,
I guess I'll clip it.
It's one of those things.
So that idea of understanding why is just extremely important and uh,
to close out this,
this section on
about face,
which again,
depending on,
I don't know,
this may be,
maybe this was just a,
um,
an exercise in my own,
in my own,
uh,
what is it,
what is that word?
Selfishness.
To be able to talk about this with people and have the mayor and,
and for me to go from this book again,
again,
I'm learning every time I read it,
but to kind of wrap it up.
So he goes on and they go on,
this is a long chapter,
and they'd go on to talk about all these different things that they did and they
did turn the fight and they did start to kill the enemy and they did start to
spare their own guys and they started fighting the guerrillas like they were
gorilla.
So he really implemented all those things that they had talked about.
So now he's getting ready to leave and he says,
uh,
the hardcore battalion proved to me everything I'd ruminated on throughout the
two years that went before all those ideas and theories on how to fight the g
and the G is gorillas.
If there was satisfaction in that,
there was much less in the fact that my success didn't make a dent in the way
the war was prosecuted.
So even though he did a great job and it really changed their battlefield for
him,
other people didn't say,
oh,
I see what they're doing.
I'm going to do that too.
Ironically,
what did was the debacle of Hamburger here?
Hill where screaming Eagle,
General Melvin's ace ordered 11 assaults up,
an extremely well fortified,
totally use,
totally useless piece of real estate as if he thought
as if he thought he was in Korea or storming crowd at Normandy,
almost 400 American men dead or wounded later.
The one,
oh one unit was king of the mountain,
but within a week be objective was abandoned.
So I don't know if you've ever heard of this,
but a hamburger hill is a huge deal.
Wast full 100 guys wounded or dead,
held it for a week and then left the ensuing horrified uproar among American
people and in Washington Bade.
Sure.
Hamburger hill was the last huge and costly battle fought by an American troops
in Vietnam.
So I guess if no one learned how to fight the war for me and the men of the
hardcore,
at least from generalizations,
they finally learned how not to.
But we were already four years into the war and there were almost four more to
go.
Okay.
Tough.
So that's about face for you.
That is a,
uh,
that is a heavy book,
figuratively and literally.
And you know,
again,
depending on,
uh,
what people thought of that,
maybe we'll come back to it and talk about it again in the future.
Okay.
That book and those experiences are kind of where this comes from,
this mindset and the attitude that I have.
How much of it do you think?
I don't,
I couldn't sit here and put a percentage on it.
Um,
from a leadership,
from a combat leadership perspective,
it is a,
it is a pretty significant amount.
You know,
it's probably in the,
in the 20 or 30% of
confirming things that I believed,
learning new things,
seeing things and reading about them and then watching them happen and,
and understanding them so that it definitely is a,
is a significant portion of some kind.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
meanwhile,
on the Internet,
on the interwebs,
we got a bunch of great questions,
bunch.
I mean,
we've got hundreds of hundreds of great questions and obviously we can't answer
them all.
So some of them we kind of compiled together.
Some of them we pulled out and you know,
what I did not do is I did not,
yeah.
Put the names of the people that submitted them.
So next time I will do that.
I think we got one person that that recommended that.
So I apologize for everyone out there on Twitter and Facebook that submitted
questions and we used them next time I'll,
I'll try and get your name in there so you'll know that I am talking to you,
but uh,
but we've got some great feedback and comments and all that.
So let's,
uh,
let's dive into some of these.
Okay.
So mental toughness,
we're going back to this.
I think this is important mental toughness because I think this is one of those
things that's
a constant endeavor for,
I would argue for everybody.
I would agree in one way or another and that,
and this question is really appropriate.
Mental toughness is not just one thing.
Some people are tough in the gym or in fights,
but weak when their wife leaves him,
for example.
Do you agree with that?
And,
and this guy,
and again,
I wish I had whoever you are,
I apologize because he actually makes a statement.
This is a statement.
Mental toughness is not one thing.
And then he quantifies that statement by saying some people are tough in the gym
or in fights,
but weak when their lives,
when their wives leaves them.
He says,
do you agree?
Well,
I agree 100% and this opens up
a whole spectrum of reality and that is that these,
that that,
what is it that crushes a person because it's different for everybody.
Everybody has this thing,
this weakness that maybe it never gets uncovered.
Maybe it does.
And the fact that he's talking about,
you know,
fighters and saying that people are tough in the gym.
They're tough and fights,
but they have some weakness that can crush them.
I think we've seen that plenty.
I mean,
just famous people,
famous fighters that this has happened to Jon Bones Jones.
I mean obviously the guy's an animal and fights.
He's an animal training in the gym,
but he has some mental weaknesses that he needs to overcome in that hopefully
you will be able to sue.
He can reach his full potential.
And I,
I hope he does,
but you know,
he's lucky he's got a good support base around him and he's got money to,
to try and solve these problems because there's a lot of people that end up with
those weaknesses or have those weaknesses and ends up crushing them.
And that's scary.
And I'll tell you what the scariest thing is,
and I think this is a great lesson and it's something that I learned over and
over again and I don't know when it exactly solidified in my brain,
but it's so disturbing and bizarre.
When you see somebody that you care about
and you watch them go down this spiral and it's so obvious what they have to do
to stop it,
to stop the downward spiral.
It's like,
Oh,
uh,
get rid of that girl or get you stop using that drug or stop drinking or do
whatever the case may be,
whatever that thing that's got them.
And you're clearly telling them to stop it and they don't.
Yeah,
because I mean,
and I think I,
I think I know what your point is going to be here,
but can you say it's clearly obvious?
It's clearly obvious,
kind of a way to put it in as it's clearly obvious on paper where you could
point it out and that person,
the person you care about,
he shoe or whatever,
they would probably agree with you and you say,
Oh,
is this holding you back you think?
Or is this jamming you up?
And they'd probably say,
yeah,
but to be like,
oh,
just simply let it go.
Let's say it was a girl would say,
I dunno.
Good girlfriend like that.
Um,
and you're like,
yeah,
the girls jamming me up snow or whatever.
Um,
and you know,
it's as simple as that.
Get rid of the girl.
But I think in everybody's different,
there's a certain need that someone has an inherent need that that girl is
fulfilling and that need is big no matter how deep down it is.
It's a big need obviously,
that they're letting that need get fulfilled in,
in,
at the expense of their goals,
their training or whatever.
So it's not that easy.
It's obvious.
Sure.
But it's just not that easy to be like,
oh,
let's just get rid of the girl.
I didn't say it was easy,
but I know you've seen this.
I think we've all seen this where you're looking at a situation with someone
that you truly care about and you want to help them.
And you could write down in two sentences what they have to do to completely
resurrect and change their life.
And it's just,
it is as easy as getting rid of a girl or a guy that's took on a life that's a
disaster.
Or it's as easy as stopping either use of drugs and alcohol or it is easy as
cutting sugar out of your diet because you're sick from it or just easy as
working out in a certain methodology to get you through this situation.
So it's,
it's,
it's horrible and it's one of those things that's,
for me,
it's taught me to,
again,
I talk about detachment law,
detach from myself to make sure I'm not that guy that doesn't have so many issue
that's holding me back and I could be doing better if I would get,
if I would take that input from other people or even better off if I could
detach and see that input myself and self correct.
And you when you can see it in someone else,
that's really what you,
what the dynamics of that relationship is.
Meaning let's say,
you know,
your friend has something,
a girl for example,
holding them back.
It's easy for you to say,
oh,
just do this.
Here's the two sentences is like going to do,
get rid of the girl,
be happy.
That's it.
It's easy because you are detached.
Yeah,
absolutely.
So the hard part is for him to actually detach,
but if he can detach,
look in,
he'd be essentially in the same position as you and probably be able to at least
be on his way to do it.
Exactly.
It's weird though.
And that's why I say people are crazy.
Like we do crazy things.
We make big mistakes,
we get emotional,
we do things that are crazy,
human beings do it.
And that's very,
very difficult to deal with.
And,
and it's really,
uh,
it can be very sad to see,
you know,
I've seen people with great,
unbelievable potential that have for all practical purposes,
cast it away for some ridiculous reason that again,
if they would have followed two bullet points on a piece of paper that said,
get rid of this girl and stop using this drug,
their life would be different and you just,
you can't help them.
Yeah.
And obviously,
you know,
getting rid of a girl,
that's clearly just an example.
It's not,
we're not saying girls or any sort of a problem.
We've seen the same thing with girls and guys and girls that had date.
This guy that's a disaster that drags them down,
whatever.
And it could be the one,
we should just say relationships and it would be unfair,
toxic relationships,
toxic relationship.
Um,
I an,
I mean you use the word ridiculous,
which,
uh,
you know,
cool.
But I don't think it is really ridiculous because if you kind of,
if you break it down,
I think,
like I said,
they have a certain need that isn't obvious to everyone,
you know,
and everyone else I even to them,
it might not be obvious,
but they have a need in there that this toxic relationship is fulfilling.
It's jamming up a bunch of other things in their life or their goals,
but it is fulfilling this little thing that they need.
We'll,
okay,
you can say that.
That's,
that's fine.
I'm not gonna argue with you.
That's the,
that's the root of the problem though,
if that need is,
if basically the,
the,
some of that need or the,
the size of that,
the size,
the bigger than the need of them achieving those goals,
which may seem weird because it's like all that teeny tiny need to be loved or
accepted is bigger than being a champion of the world or be,
it seems weird,
but from an individual standpoint on the,
in how they feel on the inside that need in a lot of times is bigger.
And that's what's crazy,
which is why I said people are crazy because he gets,
so you make that determination and you can't help them.
That's the piece.
You cannot help them and you can try,
you can paint it out for him.
You can tell them a thousand times,
a thousand different ways.
Yeah.
I think,
yeah,
I think there are ways to help.
Obviously.
I think it's like through like a therapy type of situation.
Not necessarily like a professional therapy maybe,
but not necessarily or something really impactful.
Yeah,
I was here.
You know,
you always hear it's gotta be the rock bottom.
The person's got to hit rock bottom somehow.
And then they realize,
okay,
I've destroyed my life.
Now I'll start moving again.
And you just wish you could help them before they hit rock bottom.
I was talking about this today with,
uh,
with Greg hitting rock bottom.
And the reason that it's typically,
and I'll just use the word easier,
it's easier to move forward when you hit rock bottom is because you're not,
you can't go any further deeper.
But what that,
I mean,
that sounds obvious,
but what that means is you're here right at the bottom.
If below here is unacceptable,
it's death or it's,
you know,
I don't know,
jail,
I dunno,
whatever,
whatever your rock bottom is.
So you can never justify,
oh,
I've been doing it this way and I'm still here.
You can never make that justification at rock bottom because I've been doing it
this way and I'm here.
That's unacceptable.
You're rock bottom.
But let's say you're not at rock bottom,
but you're pretty junk yard and you're not doing good,
but you're making it,
you're handling it.
Sure,
your job sucks.
But I'm still here.
You know,
I still got my car to justify.
Yes.
Okay,
I need to make an improvement.
I'm going to start,
I'm going to start on Monday.
I'm gonna,
I'm gonna make an improvement.
So they started Monday.
Okay,
if it goes good,
Tuesday goes good,
Wednesday,
some temptation comes and whatever the drugs or drinking,
whatever,
when they're kind of exhausted from putting in that effort to change and it's
like,
okay,
I'll just have one beer.
Okay,
I'll just,
okay,
I'll just start drinking again because really,
I'm cool with it.
You know,
I,
I made it,
it's not that bad.
They've accepted their station in life and somebody accepts their station in
life,
then I guess they're not going to be motivated to do anything.
Right.
So,
and that accepting their station is essentially their justification for
relapsing.
But when you're at rock bottom,
you can't do that.
So,
I mean,
obviously people's rock bottom,
they're different,
like I said,
but,
um,
that's the reason that it's,
that it's easier.
I know it sounds crazy,
but it's easier to move forward when you're at rock bottom.
It's tough stuff.
So,
um,
yeah,
mental toughness yet,
like how you said it is,
um,
it's different for everyone and you can be met.
It's not an across the board thing.
You're just mentally tough to tie this back into mental toughness is again,
going back to detachment.
You know,
I'm,
I'm glad we're,
most of the people listening to this aren't dealing with a situation where
they've got some grievous scenario going on and their life is on a downward
spiral.
Hopefully we're downward spiral is that you slept in until five 30.
You know,
that's,
that's the type of thing where you want to catch yourself.
And like we talked about earlier,
you want to get those little disciplines in place and,
and build upon those and become better.
Yeah.
Stay out of them.
Nevermind the rock bottom.
Let's get to the top of this bad boy.
That's what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
And it,
and with that,
I think this might be kind of obvious,
but it's important to recognize what elements or what aspects of your life that
you are not quite as tough mentally at,
you know,
like if,
if you have a weakness for beard alcohol,
then recognize that.
Or I have a weakness for giving up when I start to get tired and training or
something like that.
Um,
you know,
recognize that.
Yeah.
And uh,
here's a quick story for you.
It's important story,
Echo tribes with a story.
Christmas Eve.
Um,
I went to the store just a real quick and it was real crowded,
that supermarket,
right?
So I go and I get
two 12 packs of beer and
some tomatoes and I have a cart,
not where I have a basket and not a cart.
So I'm carrying it.
So all the lines are long.
So I'm,
so I'm standing in one of the lines and um,
and I'm holding the basket with the 12 pack of beer in one hand with the
tomatoes and the other 12 pack of beer and the other hand.
So that's,
you know,
it's not like terribly heavy,
but it can get heavy after a little while.
So the line is real long.
So I'm going to be in that line for a while.
So after a while,
you know,
you shoulda started getting tired and right.
Then I recognize,
okay,
he,
this can be a small exercise in mental toughness.
Just a small one,
not a,
you know,
not a marathon and nothing like that.
But you know what I'm going to do,
I'm just going to hold these until,
until I put them on the thing.
I'm not going to put them down because right now I kind of want to put them
down.
So what I did is I made it consciously made it an exercise.
So I held them and every little thing that would happen,
this guy is not taking,
um,
or this guy's not being as quick as he should be.
Boom.
That that's another element added to the mental toughness exercise.
No,
what he's going to write a check.
Yeah.
So I did it.
I totally did it.
It took maybe,
I would say 10 minutes,
a good 10 minutes of just holding it,
you know?
Um,
so I put my,
my,
uh,
my stuff on the,
on the little carousel or whatever to get it checked out.
And I remember thinking,
okay,
that's one little exercise in mental toughness,
a little workout myth,
mental toughness done.
Now I realize as a demonstration of mental toughness,
that's quite lame,
but as far as recognizing a potential situation where you could be mentally
weak,
using it as an exercise to be,
to help with mental toughness as a concept,
that's an important element.
And you know,
what I liked the best about that whole story was the fact that you had to
mentally detach yourself and recognized,
because that's the true exercise in my mind,
is having the ability to be outside yourself and look at yourself and say,
you're being weak right now.
Or here's an opportunity that's real triumph.
Yeah.
On a small scale.
When ab or it,
we're going to meet with you.
But if you can just start thinking to yourself that way,
that small little exercise can turn into a little bit bigger exercise and,
and next thing you know,
you're in a detrimental situation.
Recognizing,
hey,
if I can practice some toughness right now where you know,
a month ago,
two months ago,
I would have straight up gave up,
but let me use this as he had another exercise and it's a big detrimental
situation.
Look,
look,
he mentally tough.
I like it.
At least on your way.
Yeah,
approved to share.
Barely approved,
approved.
None.
The less.
Next question.
Okay.
Next question is my son who's seven,
seven years old and I want to get into Jujitsu.
What lessons has it taught you in life?
Well,
you know,
I talk about your due to all the time because I do think it's a great metaphor
for life.
Some of the things that it teaches you without a doubt is it teaches you
humility because it's not going to teach you humility.
Bice telling you,
hey,
be humble,
be humble.
It's going to teach you humility because you are going to get submitted and be
forced to surrender to people that are smaller than you,
that are weaker than you,
that aren't as good athletes as you.
And that's going to happen on almost a daily basis when you first start out.
So there's no doubt about that.
It's going to teach you about respect.
And I had a,
I had a buddy in the marine corps,
uh,
great dude,
big H.
I know you're out there somewhere.
And he was,
he was a bad ass.
I mean,
he looked like a superhero,
super strong just,
and he,
and he grew up in,
so I think he grew up in Texas.
He was some kind of a gang member in Texas,
had a rough childhood and he was,
he was a bad ass.
Scary dude.
Super Nice.
But,
but,
but definitely could bring it.
And when he started training after like a month,
you know,
I said,
so,
you know,
what do you,
what do you think of Jujitsu?
And he said,
uh,
you know,
I used to think I was bad ass and now I don't want to mess with anybody because
I don't know if they've been training for three months and if they have been,
I'm in trouble.
So you definitely will learn respect from Jujitsu
discipline.
You know,
we were just kinda talking earlier and I was talking about training today and
how I just did not feel like training today.
I was all beat up,
I was tired of soar and there's only one thing that got me on the mat.
And that's just having the discipline to get on there and know that I needed to
train.
So there's nobody,
I don't care who you are.
That feels like training every single day,
seven days a week.
But if you want to get better and you want to reach the goal,
then you have to do it.
And so it teaches you about discipline.
And,
and I would say from a mental perspective,
one of the coolest things that Jujitsu teaches you is it teaches you that
maneuver and that tactics and that brains that those things Trump strength and
Trump meeting force on force.
And I talk about this all the time in psychological situations and it's too bad.
I wish everybody in the world train Jujitsu because you have all metaphors that
you could tell them.
So it's great when I have a client that actually trains Jujitsu because then I
can or understands MMA or watches martial arts or watches UFC because then you
can use these examples.
But you know,
the classic case in the mental confrontation is people have a tendency to want
to go,
you know,
fist on fist.
And if you say one thing,
if you say method a,
I say method B,
and we'll just going to bang those two methods together and see who you know.
A lot of times it's see who has more rank and you know what?
You know what Echo,
I'm in charge.
So we're going with method.
Well now you're going to do what I say,
but you're not going to do it willingly.
You're going to sabotage it.
Whatever the case may be.
That's not true.
Jujitsu.
Jujitsu is,
is using maneuver and setting people up and,
and being more crafty.
That's what you did to his and that's how you win.
And that's how you win,
not just on the mat,
not just but in life as well.
And it does the same thing on the battlefield.
You know,
we,
oh,
we have a little saying in combat.
He who flanks first wins,
meaning the person that gets around to the side and attacks from an unexpected
direction is going to win.
And it's the same thing in it mentally in Jujitsu.
And it's the same thing in,
in,
you know,
mental confrontations with people.
It's,
it's who is going to maneuver and it's always this indirect approach.
That's the key phrase that I use when I'm dealing with someone that's not a
Jujitsu person.
And I'm talking about how do they deal with their boss that does does this or
their subordinate that has a big head or whatever.
I tell them,
listen,
you need to use an indirect approach because the direct approach is not going to
get through to this person.
I was,
I have a,
was doing some executive coaching the other day and had this guy,
he explained the personality of this guy that worked for him and the guy that
had worked for him had been moved underneath him in a,
in a reorganization and it was one of those guys,
he's a senior guy who he should have been appear,
but now all of a sudden he's reporting to him and he's been in the business for
32 years and he knows stuff better than I do.
And then the guy says to me,
so I've brought the guy in and I've told them I'm going to coach him and this is
what I'm going to help him with.
And I said,
okay,
you are no way is this guy going to accept that,
that you're going to coach him and it's,
he's not in his personality.
You can't go.
Whereas this guy that I was talking to call him Mike,
I said,
Mike,
you want to be coached.
You want to be helped you have an open mind.
If I came to you and said,
hey,
I want a coach,
you'd be like,
that's great.
This guy is the complete opposite.
If I go to him and say,
Hey,
I'm going to coach you,
he's going to say,
I don't need coaching,
and even if I outrank him and I say,
no,
I'm going to coach you.
He's going to do it reluctantly and he's going to sabotage it and he's never
going to put any effort into it and he's going to actually do the opposite to
prove you wrong,
right?
That's the direct approach.
Jujitsu is the indirect approach.
So what you do with this guy,
when you're going to coach him,
as you say,
listen,
you know what I need is you're so much more experienced in this.
I need some help running the organization.
Can you come and help me get things in order and give me a hand straightening
things out and also can you fill me in on what we can improve inside of our
department?
And when that,
when you do that,
now all of a sudden he's just started to telling me what all the problems are
and now I can discretely and indirectly coach him on how we're going to fix
those problems.
That's Jujitsu and that's one of the lessons you learned from it.
Yeah.
And,
and not to mention that the thought of more obvious things where you know,
it's a great workout.
You get um,
you know,
kind of this,
men actually just be all people.
They have us sort of aggression kind of built into them and it's a spectrum.
Some people more than others,
you can engage,
I understand what you're trying to tell me.
You can engage in Jujitsu and be a pretty accurate simulation of whether it be a
fight or any kind of aggressive combat situation and it's still be safe and
doable where you can do it again and again.
You can go,
you know,
the next day it's,
it's,
if you go spar right boxing,
you can't really do it every day and you can't go all out.
If you go all out and do it everyday,
you can get messed up in Jujitsu,
you can do that.
And so you get that satisfaction when you,
when you leave.
And it's kind of strange because when you get the satisfaction from that,
you kind of want to do it some more,
you know?
So most people when you talk to these people who have been doing it for over a
year,
I talked to anyone you know,
that has been doing it more than one year.
I would say my argument would be 85% or more will tell you that at some point
they were addicted to it.
That they'd go to sleep at night and they'd be thinking about a move or
something like that.
And to go along with the things that you,
just,
the obvious things because you're right,
there's some obvious things.
The,
the workout,
it's a great workout.
You grit more in tune with your own body.
You learn how to handle yourself in a real fight.
And,
and it does give you,
absolutely gives you confidence and confidence that you can handle a situation
confidence that,
uh,
that's coupled with the respect that you look at everyone and say,
hey,
you know what,
this guy might be able to,
uh,
this guy might know more than I do.
So I'm gonna respect him.
But at the same time,
you know that,
hey,
I'm going to be able to at least know what I'm doing very confidently.
So it helps out across the board.
And it's definitely a,
a great sports.
So with the new year approaching,
what have you changed your mind about is as far as two 50
in 2015?
Yeah.
Well,
the biggest thing that's been a radical change,
cause I'm,
I always talk about how I have big open mind and all that,
but the fact of the matter is I,
I'm very set in my ways and I kind of follow patterns and I,
I believe things and,
and my beliefs are open for,
for changing,
but a lot of times they just don't get changed.
Uh,
okay.
So one thing that's been radically different about me in 2015 and it's been kind
of a bizarre ride,
is the fact that I am now
out there in the world and you know,
people,
obviously when I made the decision with leaf that we were going to write this
book,
we knew that we were going to be out there and,
and people are going to know us now.
The book has been more successful than,
you know,
it's kind of been the Max level of success that I thought I could achieve.
You know,
I thought there was a spectrum and we definitely achieved a great success and
we're,
we're super,
super happy about that,
but that means we're even more out there then we thought we're going to be.
Then on top of that,
there's been this whole Internet phenomenon of they don't go on the Tim Ferriss
show with Tim and going on the Joe Rogan show with Joe and then doing this
podcast and being on Twitter and all these things,
being on Facebook.
I mean,
I didn't literally did not have a Facebook account,
literally did not have a Twitter account.
Never been on before.
And then now I have,
you know,
I'm on it and in it and communicating with people and I think that's,
people would tell me like,
hey,
social media is cool.
You can link up with other people.
And I was definitely,
I didn't want to link up with other people.
I didn't want to have my friends and I didn't really want to meet other people.
But now that I'm there,
it's awesome.
Honestly,
it's awesome to have people all over the world.
I have people all over the world,
especially cause you know,
I do the thing in the morning with my watch and at four,
four 30 in the morning,
I take a picture of my watch and I posted on Twitter and I get those because
other people do it.
And,
and now my Twitter is filled with people from every time zone throughout the day
that wake up at four 30 in the morning and they still get their workout on.
And that's,
that's cool man.
That's very cool to see that there's other people in the world that have the
same kind of mentality that want to be better,
that want to improve that wanna do their best.
And I think that's a,
I think that's been pretty cool to see.
And it's also been,
it's,
it's been,
honestly,
it almost makes me feel
like I'm in a leadership position in a way again because I've got like people
that are saying,
hey,
thanks for putting this out there and thanks.
And it makes you feel just like,
just like being in a leader at combat leadership position where you feel humbled
by these guys that are doing so well or I feel the same way with these people.
Humbled by the fact
that these people are out there and they're communicating with me and talking to
me and saying I inspire them and I always write back,
man,
you inspire me.
You know,
that inspires me that you're out,
you know,
kicking ass and,
and there's these,
Yo,
I was talking about like the single moms are the single dads that are out there.
They're getting up earlier than me and they're going to work,
you know,
and that's job number one and they're getting home late.
So that's,
that's inspiring to me.
And,
um,
I think it's been a pretty cool ride so far.
Any other weird thing is I have no idea where the ride is going.
I do.
I do not know.
And I'm all about plans and I'm a little bit of a control freak.
But just to be out there and on this roller coaster,
did you have no idea where it's going.
So that's,
that's pretty entertaining to,
to,
to connect with,
um,
with people who have the same interest in you and not all interests,
obviously,
but just some of the same interests as you.
It is kind of refreshing because if you go just through your day to day life,
right?
And someone is extreme as you are,
it's going to be hard to find someone to relate to in specific ways or even in a
general way.
It's gonna be harder for someone like you,
right?
So when you get these little tidbits of people doing the same thing is you?
And it's like,
Dang,
I'm relating to these people just in that small little way every day or however
often you check your Twitter,
you know,
and it's kind of refreshing and it reminds you that there are people like that
out there who want to wake up early in and be disciplined and work hard and then
face the day and get stuff done or whatever.
And you might not see that in your day to day life outside of the Internet,
like in your,
in your real life.
You might not see that.
So you might have this feeling of,
man,
am I the only one who's trying to get this stuff done?
You know,
almost like that kind of thought.
Right.
And I'm definitely not.
Yeah,
and it's,
and you're right,
it is,
it is reassuring.
Yeah.
And it's cool to communicate with these people.
They're fired up.
I've got a bunch of firemen and police officers that are on there that are fired
up every day.
Bunch of,
obviously a bunch of former military people.
But then,
you know,
cause I have kind of a weird background.
I get these crazy old,
the hardcore punk rock kids and you know,
they're communicating with me and it's just,
it's very interesting,
very interesting.
And it's been an interesting ride.
I'm like,
um,
I'm curious to see where it all ends up.
Yeah,
yeah.
I do think that the more experience you have with people,
the more good stuff you can learn that,
that people have in them regardless of stuff.
You might not agree with them,
but if you can find,
have more experiences with more people in whatever way,
you'll be more informed.
And this,
and this,
this really,
the fear or the rejection I had of social media was based on what I talked about
earlier with that Tom Wolfe book,
the electric Koolaid,
acid test,
mi,
Mi,
Mi.
And I always felt that social media was me,
me,
here's a picture of me.
Here's me doing this,
here's my food and this is my car and this is me,
me.
And he just
felt so disturbing.
And,
but now I,
like you're saying,
I realize that this,
this social media,
at least the way that I'm involved in it right now,
it's not about me.
It's about we,
and there's a group of people that have the similar mindset and some of them are
more into it.
Some of them aren't,
but they're there and they communicate with me and it's not me,
it's we.
And I think that's,
that's,
that's pretty cool.
Yeah,
for sure.
Well,
it is everything.
It's a spectrum.
But I think,
I think we all feel that even if we're people who are really into the Internet,
really into Facebook,
really into Twitter and Instagram,
if people overdo it,
me,
here's a Selfie of me in front of the mirror.
If you see 10 pictures of,
of them taking a picture of themselves in front of the mirror,
that's a me,
me,
me situation for sure.
They're just on that side of the spectrum.
That's all.
There's,
there's all kinds of different people and I think the majority people are in
that we,
we category.
Yeah,
sure.
It's something about me.
But there there is no we without me.
Do you know?
No,
it's cool.
Uh,
I don't like people that send me stuff on Twitter that I get pictures every day
of peoples of watches.
I get pictures of their jump rope or their kettle bell.
Like no one said,
I don't know what any of these people look like,
which I guess is kind of bizarre and,
but that's,
you're right.
They're not about me.
Me,
me either about we,
and it's like having a little,
a little group,
a little gang to get after it.
I sent you a picture of me and it wasn't for 30,
like more like noon.
It's four 30 in the afternoon actually was like 2:00 PM.
Um,
so your sleep,
next question,
your sleep routine,
you get less than eight hours sleep from what I know.
Okay.
So your sleep routine,
how many hours of sleep do you get and what are the techniques you used to get
to sleep if you're not tired,
you know,
do you take naps,
do that,
does that work?
Uh,
okay.
So I generally sleep.
I try and sleep at least five,
five and a half or six hours a night.
It generally ends up being somewhere between five and five and a half.
Generally I feel not good if I sleep for,
you know,
seven hours.
I don't feel good.
I feel groggy.
Uh,
I don't know why that is.
I,
that's the way it is though.
I feel good and I sometimes I feel better when I slept 4.5 hours,
otherwise known as four and a half hours.
So,
so there's no doubt that I don't need a ton of sleep.
Um,
that being said,
sometimes I do feel tired and sometimes,
you know,
come the afternoon,
especially if I have to do something boring or tedious and that's when I'll feel
really legitimately tired.
If I'm up and moving,
I don't need to sleep.
I actually don't need to sleep.
Like I can go long periods of times without sleeping.
If there's something actively engaging my mind,
it,
especially something that's going to be partially physical,
you know,
cause you sitting down,
reading a book when you're tired is,
is tough.
So,
uh,
I do and,
and power naps are great and this is something that I learned the part of it in
high school and part of it in basic seal training,
when I was in high school,
my anatomy and physiology teacher,
I used to go in,
walk by his room at lunchtime and he'd be in there with his feet up on the desk
in like as chair all low and he'd just be in there sitting,
you know,
doing a little bit of work and one day I said,
hey,
you know,
you look kind of relaxed in there.
And he said,
hey,
this is a technique.
And I said,
what do you mean?
He said,
put your,
when you,
when you rest,
elevate your feet above your heart because your veins are stressed out,
you know,
the one way valves and yours veins,
you've got blood pooled up in areas and your feed,
you want to get that stuff out of there.
So elevate your feet above your heart.
And I was like,
oh,
that makes sense.
Then in seal training,
you'd come back from let's say breakfast in the morning or lunch and you get
back to the barracks and you have to grab gear to get ready for whatever the
next evolution was going to be.
Well,
they'd give you time to grab the gear,
but they'd also give you time to,
you know,
use the bathroom or whatever.
And it would literally be,
they'd say,
all right,
we gotta be back out here in eight minutes.
Well,
it take you one minute to get your gear on.
So if I'm gonna have to go to the bathroom,
I would go in my room.
I would lay down on the floor,
I'd put my feet up on the bed,
and I would set my alarm clock for six minutes and I would get a power nap.
And you'd fall asleep almost immediately because you're so tired.
So He'd just fall asleep.
Six minutes later,
boom.
You wake up and you feel refreshed and you feel recharged.
If you sleep for longer than that,
sometimes you start to feel groggy again.
So you gotta be careful that you don't sleep for too long.
But yeah,
try the elevated feet above the heart.
Eight minute power nap when you're feeling tired and it'll make you feel better.
You got to set your alarm clock so you don't,
so that eight minutes doesn't turn into two and,
and that's it.
You know,
I look,
I know and probably,
uh,
I know I should probably sleep more and I would like to do that.
I'll try.
I try and do that sometimes.
Um,
but also my mind,
it's,
it's not like a big choice that I'm making,
you know,
when,
when I'm thinking about something,
it cannot be stopped.
It cannot be stopped.
When I'm thinking about something,
it just goes and I,
in my mind,
it feels like I'm going down,
um,
various tunnels of thought.
That's literally what it feels like.
I'm going down these various tunnels of thought and one leads to another.
I'm taking a left turn,
right turn.
I'm getting all these ideas and I can't sleep.
Yeah.
So,
you know,
and I would imagine that a lot of people are like that where if they have a lot
going on in their life,
you know,
where they can't get these certain thoughts out of the head,
good or bad,
you know,
sometimes you just excited about something and you can't stop thinking about it
and you know,
whatever.
Um,
but if that's a problem,
if he gets in the way your sleep and it's jamming you up the next day,
then I'm sure you can,
you know,
I'm sure meditation can kind of help is from what I hear about men.
Yeah,
maybe,
I don't know.
He didn't know anything about that.
But I will say this,
if you,
if you want to go to bed earlier,
you have to get up earlier.
Like it doesn't work in reverse.
You can't just force yourself to go to sleep at night.
You have to just wake up earlier and be more tired at the end of the day.
And I love the feeling of when I'm so tired that my,
my head hits the pillow and I fall asleep immediately.
I love that feeling of just exhaustion.
That's what I'm going for every day.
See if I can just burn it,
burn it out and just be so tired at the end of the day.
So that's my sleep routine probably made all kinds of doctors and stuff angry at
me.
Sorry.
Sorry Doc Parsley.
I know,
I think they say that the,
the,
the ideal amount of sleep is seven and a half hours or something like that.
But I would imagine it'd be different from person.
Like if you're used to getting six hours sleep,
it doesn't your body conform,
like get your sleep cycles.
I think they come form to that six hours said they have Dr and Dr Recko has
spoken.
Yup.
Your sleep schedule conform.
I learned that on the Internet.
Um,
so in regards to,
you know,
achieving goals and just your pursuits in life,
how do you deal with loved ones who seem to determine or who seemed determined
to hold you back from your goals?
Um,
and that's,
I guess that's kind of assuming that you have loved ones that are determined to
hold you back from you.
All right,
well that
in issue,
this is one of those questions that came in and I think you voted positive on
this question was let's answer this question and why did you,
why were you so why did you want to answer this question?
And not that I've had this experience where that answered this question or that
asks this question.
I put a line through it,
echo brought it back from the dead.
So all cause I think people deal with this.
I,
I don't,
I haven't
experienced this personally,
but I've seen it happen.
I've seen it in other people were.
And I think
part of this is just my philosophy,
but I think a big part of this,
I believe a big part of this is you can apply it to every situation where it's a
supposedly loved one,
whether it be your family,
spouse,
whatever,
um,
where they will hold you back sometimes.
And
sometimes it can be because they're like jealous of you or something.
So,
and not necessarily jealous.
So they're going to say,
um,
you know,
they're going to lie to you and say,
hey,
that's a bad idea.
When it's really a good one or nothing like that,
just they'll just be focusing on the bad part of it.
So let's say,
let's say you were unemployed for a little bit,
you've been working hard to get this job and you finally get a job and then
you're,
I dunno,
a parent or whatever says,
well it's about time,
you know,
so instead of Dang,
you're,
you know,
you got this job,
congratulations.
They focus on the negative and that can,
that can be discouraging on a personal level.
Like,
like there was no,
there was no happiness,
there was no encouragement.
There was no,
no one's saying that no one making me feel like they were on my team,
make me feel like I'm alone in doing this.
People do do that.
And then they do a bunch of other stuff as well,
telling you the other part that I said,
they will tell you it's a bad idea to start this new company.
You know,
cause they're,
they may be afraid subconsciously or whatever that,
you know,
he might outshine them where you might do something good when they haven't done
anything good.
So,
yes.
So how do you deal with that?
Um,
and of course a bunch of other ways that they can kind of get in the way.
this probably isn't going to be anything new,
but you know how you surround yourself with likeminded people or you surround
yourself by certain types of people in,
you're going to start to become like that.
So I'm not saying disown any family members or loved ones,
I'm not saying that,
but you have to create boundaries,
specific boundaries to these people.
And I know a lot of people say,
well,
that's my family and I can't change that,
or that's my family.
So,
you know,
um,
and they feel like they're under this obligation to essentially give away part
of their life.
But I think it should be the opposite.
I think that that's your family.
So they should understand that you're on a path to success or you want to be on
a path to success.
And if they're in the way,
then they're in the way in.
Those boundaries have to be created.
If they can't handle that,
then there,
there is someone who,
who is against you in your path.
And
if you're on a successful path and someone is against you,
just that the eventuality is that they're going to be cut out of your life.
And if,
if they can respect the boundaries and boom you can and you can keep living your
life and they can be them and you can,
I love them for them,
no matter how negative there.
And you can have all that,
but if you don't,
they're either going to bring you down or you got to come and cut them out of
your life,
family or not.
I think family should be held in a higher standard then your friend or your
whatever because they're,
they're your family.
They're,
they're the one who should be treating you good.
So you're saying your loved ones are treating you bad.
They're are the ones that shit,
they're the last people that should be treating you bad.
They're your loved ones.
So if they're not treating you good,
then like I said,
they're the one in violation that you for pursuing your path.
And you know,
and not giving them the attention.
We're not going to their house every other Saturday or whatever like you're
supposed to do whatever.
It's their fault or not their fault,
but it's their responsibility to support you and if they're not then like anyone
else who's not supporting you,
they should either have a boundary between you and them or be cut out of your
life.
I think that's fairly sound advice.
I'll tell you that a couple of things from my perspective,
first of all,
I think that many people are negative in the world and to coin a term that is
used very often these days,
a lot of people are haters and they don't want you to succeed in.
And we would see that we didn't see that in the seal teams because seal teams is
a bunch of really super competitive guys and everybody is competitive with each
other.
And when someone starts doing something well other people get can get jealous of
them pretty quickly.
And so that,
like I had one,
a friend of mine who he decided that hey,
he was going to try and take like a year off or get get orders to go to an ivy
league school while he was in the seal teams.
And he had applied and actually got into it.
But you know,
uh,
one of the best colleges in the world to go there for a year and get a degree
and you know,
that's awesome.
And he came to me and he said,
hey,
you know,
I've got some guys that are telling me I shouldn't do this.
It's going to be bad for my career and this,
that the other thing.
And I said,
Bro,
I hate to tell you this.
These guys are just,
they're haters.
They're just jealous.
The fact that you thought of this,
the fact that you went on a limb,
the fact that you made this happen,
the fact that you put an application,
the fact that you took the the test to get into the school and now you're going
to go there,
you're going to have that on your resume,
which is awesome.
You know what?
Don't worry about anybody else.
They're,
they're just,
you know,
I hate to use the word jealous,
but they're jealous.
The fact that you're going to go out and make this happen,
which I thought was a,
I thought that was awesome.
The other kind of contrary advice to what you just said is when people aren't
approving what you're doing and they're saying negative things to you and
they're not giving you the praise that you want for your,
what you're doing,
that's your fault.
You're the one that's wanting praise.
You're the one that's looking for approval.
You're the one that wants all the support,
like,
no,
I don't expect anything from anybody because people are crazy as I briefed
earlier,
and they're not going to give you support.
If they're one of these people that are,
that are negative,
they're going to be negative no matter what you do.
So you can't be be hung up on getting their approval and getting their support.
You go forth and conquer regardless of what people are trying to do to told you
back,
and one's going to hold you back.
Who's gonna hold you back?
How's that going to happen?
It don't let them hold you back.
Yeah,
in a,
and I agree with that last
part.
You don't let them hold you but hold you back.
But here,
here's an example.
Let's say,
let's say you're pursuing this,
I dunno,
business degree or something,
or you're,
you're,
you want to start a tee shirt company and it's going to,
it takes all this time.
You've got to really get your knowledge down and you really do all your research
and stuff and it takes a lot of time.
Let's say it takes 15 hours a day,
every single day while you're getting this thing up and running.
But you visit
your mom on the weekends typically,
and you go down there,
you help her with her yard work.
Just cause she wants company,
you know,
you do all this stuff.
If you don't,
she makes you feel guilty.
If you can't make it or I don't know you're sick or something,
So you're under this obligation.
When you grow up,
it kind of gets ingrained in into you.
You know,
like these relationships with your loved ones and not to mention they're your
loved ones.
They're supposed to love you,
you know,
and you're supposed to love them.
Um,
so I think you do care about the support.
I think that's a natural part of it.
If that's your loved ones,
I'm not saying like your friend or your neighbor is not recognizing my,
my success or whatever.
That's your loved ones.
Typically,
that's,
if anyone's gonna praise you,
you're going to hope that they're the first ones.
Yeah.
But you can't be hung up on it.
Especially if they're crazy.
Right.
And that's,
that's my point.
That was your point.
Yeah.
So accepted.
So you sit and you,
that's how they can hold you back.
If it's ingrained in you that you have to be there for your mom.
If she's trained you from a little kid to be to say,
you owe me,
I gave you life,
then yeah.
Then again,
that's your fault.
If you're letting them hold you back from,
Right.
You need to take ownership of it and move on.
So yeah,
exactly right.
And that's what I mean by you create those barriers yet you have to suck it up
or,
or kind of model in your life and how you would say about,
um,
about other people or other situations when you're in a job or,
or leadership situation where you can make them understand,
if you could make them understand what you're doing.
Yeah.
That's ideal.
Where you can maintain the integrity of the relationship.
You are correct.
Now you just hit a home run because you're going back to the basic principles.
You have to let people understand why and you have to make them understand why
it's going to be beneficial for them.
You know,
the long run.
I used to dealing with guys when we were working hard,
uh,
you know,
training guys for combat or we were training for combat and you think,
oh well,
you know,
you've got to let these guys get home to their families.
You know,
they got to go home tonight,
let's let them out early.
And I'd say,
look,
the best thing we can do for these guys to help them and their families is to
train them as hard as possible.
So in the long run where they come home from combat,
that's what we're here to do.
And everybody understands that message.
So it's the same thing.
You're right when you explain to your family members,
this is why I'm doing what I'm doing,
this is how it's going to benefit me,
which will thereby benefit you,
which pulled thereby benefit or whole family.
Yes,
that is correct.
Explain the why
next question.
Um,
what is the,
what are the bullet points in keys to success for motivating and engaging your
team of leaders?
Well first of all we just kind of covered that when we talked to with uh,
about about face for a solid hour,
which is,
which is one of the questions here.
I actually answered this question last time.
So this is a question that you hear all the time is you know,
what can I do to motivate these guys?
How can we get them engaged?
And first of all,
I want to say that leadership,
although there are basic principles,
fundamental principles that can be used,
it is not something that can be bulletized.
It is,
it is like trying to bulletize how you play guitar or trying to bulletize how
you play the violin.
It is a,
it is an art,
it is a practice and there are many,
many different ways to,
to manipulate that instrument to make it,
make the noise that you want it to make.
And that's what leadership is.
Leadership is not follow these four steps and you will become a good leader.
It doesn't work that way.
It is an art.
Now again,
just like there's principles behind music,
there's principles behind leadership and that fundamental principles stay the
same.
But how you engage with those and the nuances involved in executing those those
principles is what makes leadership so challenging,
which again is why we have a book,
which is why we have a business,
which is why there's leadership schools around the world because it is a very
challenging thing to do.
So you know the bullets are I almost after saying that,
you know,
what are the bullets?
Well,
you got to build relationships.
You've got to listen to people,
you've got to give respect.
You got to the main thing we talked about tonight with about face,
you got to answer that.
Why people got to understand why you're doing what you're doing and understand
what their perspective is.
So you got to communicate with them.
It's all those things.
But I think it's important to realize that leadership is a learning constant
learning process.
It's nuanced tool.
There aren't any bulletized lists that are going to make you into a great leader
tomorrow.
What?
There are principles that you can learn and understand and interpret and apply
in different ways with different amplitudes at different times with different
personalities.
Its mayhem.
It's may him.
That's what makes it so challenging and so fun.
And I,
I,
that's what makes me love to talk about leadership because there's,
it's an infinitely complex thing on,
in so many different ways.
But all that being said,
it is something that does follow core principles.
And so learn those core principles,
know those core principles and that's what will make you good leader.
But don't look for a quick solution.
Look for a comprehensive,
a comprehensive,
uh,
mass of knowledge and technique and understanding that will make you
a better leader.
Check.
In your opinion,
what are the best tactics in order to remain focus?
Okay.
This is individual for me because I know different people have different
techniques.
If you're,
if you're using whatever take Nick's you have and they're not working well then
they're not working.
So try mine.
So mine are when I have to do something focused.
No music,
no video,
no TV playing in the background,
none of that.
No phone,
turn that off and and get focused on the task at hand.
So what are you going to do to focus on the task at hand?
You have to predetermine
there's a,
there's a thing we used to use in the seal team,
seal teams.
It's called task condition standard.
Here's the task,
here's the conditions,
better involved in the task and here's the standards that you have to complete
the task too.
So I like to think of when I have to focus on something,
I set up my own task conditions and standards for it.
And a good example for me was writing our book when we were writing extreme
ownership.
Lafe wrote about half of it.
I wrote about half of it.
We actually wrote a little bit more of half each because we,
we both wrote chapters that aren't in there and,
but it was a lot of writing to do.
And how do you do that?
How did I do it?
I'll tell you,
I set the task conditions and standards for what I needed to do.
For me it was what did I have to do?
The task was to write the condition was I,
I was trying to write the draft so I knew it didn't have to be perfect and I got
perfect out of my head cause perfect can be bad.
And the standard was,
I said I'm every day I'm going to write a thousand words regardless.
I want to write a thousand words and I tried to do it in an hour or less.
So that's what I did.
I made no music,
no phone,
no videos,
playing in the background.
I have an hour,
I'm gonna sit down,
I'm gonna get this done.
So to me that's a form of motivation.
When you say,
okay,
this is what I'm going to do,
this is how I'm going to do it,
this is how long it's going to take me.
I'm going to get it done.
I'm probably going to try and get it done faster than an hour.
And I used to time myself and be like,
Hey,
that only took me,
you know,
49 minutes.
That's pretty good.
Kind of like a crossfit exercise.
Yeah.
Like you're going into it with a,
with a challenge.
And then you go about it in a,
in a disciplined way.
Right.
And that's going to be the core of a lot of answers I give.
Yeah.
I think I'm going to disagree on a personal level from a personal standpoint.
I mean,
uh,
with the no music thing,
I think the music in my case helps.
I think for a lot of people,
music helps.
It might,
when I talk specifically about writing than music does not help me.
Especially music with like words,
like if there's lyrics,
you know?
Um,
but if it's like,
um,
like somebody I know or like that.
Okay.
Echo,
you are clear to listen to piano as you create
some violence.
Marcus driving that had worked to force the cello.
Um,
any it was there more to that one.
No scoring.
I'm good.
Any advice on balancing the thousands of things you have to do every day?
Yeah.
Again,
chapter in the book it's called prioritize and execute,
prioritize and execute.
That is the name of the chapter that is a,
one of the basic principles.
One of the laws of combat that we used in that is that you're going to have all
these problems happening on the battlefield.
They're all going to happen at the same time because Murphy's law and when they
do,
if you try and handle them all at once and you try and do them all at once,
you will fail.
So what you have to do is you have to prioritize them and execute.
So in business that looks the same way,
you know,
you've got all these problems,
all these initiatives that you're trying to start,
these things you got to handle and that's,
that's good.
And that looks very similar on the battlefield.
On a personal level,
it's the same principle.
But I'll tell you what I considered to be,
for lack of a better word.
Um,
I will,
I will use this word.
I will tell you the hack,
the hack for this e and this is no genius thing here.
If you really want to get things done,
make a list of what you need to do the next day,
make it an a priority.
Uh,
what you actually need to do is schedule the time that you're going to execute
those tasks.
This is a piece that a lot of people miss.
So I guess it is a little bit bigger of a hack then.
Then I gave it credit for you have to say,
okay,
I've got to do these six things tomorrow.
You've got to put on your schedule when you are going to do those things.
And that really drives execution because it puts a time limit on it and it makes
you get on there and get it started and get it done so you can move onto the
next task.
So task lists and calendars should actually be connected,
you know,
intimately.
And then once you have that in place,
you get up and you go and you get it done.
Wake up early and make it happen.
Prioritize and execute.
That's what we do.
New Year's resolutions,
2016 is coming up in a few days.
So what's your one thing for 2016 that you need to do such that by doing it,
everything else will be easier and or unnecessary.
And that's,
that's one of the new year's resolution questions we pulled out,
cause I've got a bunch of them because everyone's thinking,
you know,
what,
what is,
what are we all going to do for the big New Year's resolution?
And I mean,
you seem pretty fired up by the new year's resolution,
so,
so what are your thoughts here?
What like my personal new year's resolution and or faults there in
a,
I've,
you know,
I'm be honest,
I haven't come up with any specific ones right now.
Maybe I will.
Maybe I won't.
But I think,
yeah,
I think all evaluate where I want to be,
where I am and the see if I can connect those dots,
whatever that looks like.
Okay.
You know,
I don't know yet,
but we'll see.
Well that sounds reward.
Anyone who just heard that in the world,
um,
please ignore or delete from your mind.
Uh,
okay.
Well actually here's the funny thing is I think that resolutions are for the
most part little feel good statements that people use to justify
a delay and execution.
That's what I think.
So I say,
don't make a new year's resolution for tomorrow.
Don't execute then execute now,
execute now.
And when I say Xq now,
I mean now and now and now and now,
and continually execute what it is you're trying to do.
And the other thing about new year's resolution is it's a year.
That's a big long chunk of time.
And that type of goal to anybody,
I don't care who you are,
a year is too long,
it's too big of a chunk.
So saying that you're going to make that type of a long term strategic goal.
It's like shooting when you shoot,
if you've ever shot weapons before,
um,
if you look at the target belonged target,
that's the 400 meters away.
If you,
if you look at a target as you look at it,
your vision can't hold that folks in,
it becomes blurry,
right?
So you have to shift back to the front side of your weapon,
which is only two and a half feet away.
And then that becomes very clear in the end.
The long distance target in the background fades a little bit,
but that's okay cause you can see that thing right in front of you and that's
what you want to make happen.
So what you want to do is you want to set those short term
goals that are closer than a year away that's going to be blurry and it's going
to lose its impact and you're going to not see it anymore.
So makeup that long term strategic goal,
that's fine.
But make sure you make some short term tactical goals that are closer now.
Now that being said,
yeah,
to close this out since the last question that I would say
don't make a new year's resolution.
Yeah.
To be a better person in 2016 I would say make a resolution to be a better
person.
Now
make it a resolution of discipline to get better,
smarter,
faster,
stronger,
healthier,
more productive,
less agitated to eat cleaner,
live more to go and do,
do all those things.
But don't do them on New Year's Eve.
Don't do them on New Year's Day.
Do them now
that
that resolution of discipline to work and follow through and maintain your will,
that'll result in the freedom that you're looking for.
And yes,
you heard it.
Once again,
discipline equals freedom.
Discipline equals freedom.
And with that,
that's all I got.
Thank you Mister Reco.
Thank you everyone that's out there listening.
We appreciate it.
We will see you next time.
Keep getting better.